Let us now introduce the linear
least mean squares formulation.
The setting is
the usual one-- we
have an unknown random variable
and another random variable,
which is our observation.
We're given enough information
so that we can, for example,
calculate the joint distribution
of these two random variables.
What we would like to
do in the least squares
methodology is to come up
with an estimator, such
that the mean squared
error of this estimator
is as small as possible.
And we have seen the general
solution to this problem.
If we consider
arbitrary estimators,
it turns out that the
best possible estimator,
the best possible function g,
is this particular function
of the observations.
Our estimator is a conditional
expectation of Theta, given X.
Now, let us look at an example
that we considered earlier.
Suppose that X and Theta
have a joint PDF, which
is uniform over this
particular region.
We did consider
this example and we
found that the
optimal estimator was
a function that had
this particular shape.
So this blue curve
here corresponds
to the function, which is
the conditional expectation
of Theta, given the
value of the observation
that we have obtained.
We notice that this
function is nonlinear,
but it is only mildly nonlinear.
The fact that it is nonlinear
is a little bit of a nuisance.
It makes it somewhat of
a complicated function.
Wouldn't it be nicer if our
estimator had turned out
to be a linear function of
the data, such as this one?
It would have been nicer,
but, unfortunately,
that's not the case.
By what if we impose
it as a constraint,
that we will only
look at estimators
that are linear
functions of the data.
What does that mean?
Mathematically
speaking, it means
that we will only
consider estimators
that depend linearly
on the data X.
Now, a and b here
are some parameters
that are for us to choose.
If I choose a and
b differently, I'm
going to get a different
red curve here.
Which one is the best red curve?
Well, we need a criterion.
But let us stick to our mean
squared error criterion.
And in that case, we're led
to the following formulation.
We want to find
choices for a and b.
That is, we want to choose
a particular red line,
so that the resulting
estimation error, the resulting
mean squared estimation error,
is as small as possible.
So what we have here
is a random variable.
Here is the value
that's going to be
given to us by our estimator.
And we look at the
associated error,
square it, and take
the expectation.
So this is the linear least
mean squares formulation.
We're looking for
an estimator, which
is a linear function
of the data.
And we want to choose the
best possible linear function.
How does it compare
to the earlier problem
of picking the best estimator?
Here we were considering
an arbitrary function g
and we were trying to find
the best possible function
of the data, which
would be our estimator.
So this was really
an optimization
over all possible functions.
Here we only have an
optimization with respect
to two numbers.
So at least mathematically, this
should be a simpler problem.
And we will see that it
has a simple solution.
Before going on to
the solution, however,
let me make one comment
that in some cases,
the linear least
squares estimation
problem is relatively
easy to solve.
And these are the cases where
the conditional expectation
turns out to be
linear in the data.
This is the best
possible estimator.
If it happens to be
linear, it's at least
as good as any other
linear estimator,
so it's also going to be the
optimal linear estimator.
That is, if the optimal
solution turns out
to be already linear, by
imposing the extra constraint
of sticking to linear
estimators is not
going to make any difference.
But for the general
case, in general,
this is not going
to be the case.
The conditional
expectation may well
turn out to be a nonlinear
function of the data,
as in this example.
And in those cases, the linear
least mean squares estimator
is going to turn
out to be different.